[Music]
okay oh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to please come
over oh hi holy [ __ ] oh my god okay I
owe this living room I don't hang out
here that much okay hi whoa hey I just
got in this game can you please not do
that I'm not okay with this whoa this
dining room are weat sometimes I prefer
eating in my room though yeah Oh God
you get uncomfortably close and I don't
like it oh man in the mouth sensitivity
is so high this is the den where we will
something watch TV
okay oh look Oh suck footage for
free.com oh do you like that Oh what is
your name oh no I don't even want to
give you a name oh boy I uh I just fired
up this game to see what it was about I
didn't know that uh I would already be
starting this is the guest room it looks
different now used to be our toy room
when we were younger
oh when we were younger oh so I know you
Oh Nick I have never heard drums
oh okay oh boy
whoa boy Oh No whoa why are you dancing
Nicholas Oh
all right let's just turn that off
oh no he didn't like that oh no he
didn't like that oh no I broke him oh
boy could you get out of my way please I
have to show you the rest of the room
house oh boy
see this is the room I share with my
brother he's not here right now holy
[ __ ] okay alrighty then something in
there
the heck is in there okay this is my
favorite show
it's girl put sweet in bunch and it is
pretty okay goodbye well this is the bed
what do you do make no decision you make
no formal choice whatever you do it this
moment's up to you press escape to be
satisfied with your decision I don't
know what's going on Oh God
this is the bathroom I'll give you some
privacy all right have fun in there I
guess okay
Oh turn on the sink wash your body part
maybe you feel clean maybe you don't
only you really don't I don't know sit
on the lid think about something you sit
on the lid and think about something
only you knows what you're thinking
about Oh God turn on the water Nick
hears from outside and there's a little
confused because in this experiences
guests usually don't take baths when
they come over oh I'm the guest
oh I am Oh take a bath okay
thanks Nick oh you did give me some
privacy didn't you
Nick Nick are you a little perturbed
that oh boy no he's in the heath totally
fine nice ass Oh bah [ __ ] oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy lie in the bed you
lie in the bed look Nick looks at you
weirdly and looks away a kind of
uncomfortable he's unsure of what you're
gonna do next
start a conversation you start a
conversation with Nick topic of your
choosing it feels a variety of different
emotions depending on the topic chosen
Nick feels surprisingly okay with you
lying down - thanks Nick
Thanks I didn't know I was aghast over
at your house oh boy this is the
bathroom I'll give you some privacy
I don't need it uh oh god no Nick no
thanks Nick okay goodbye Nick did I
leave okay
all right Nick you know what maybe I
should maybe I shouldn't be here Nick
started to think maybe I should be here
do denied stared in silence Nick looks
at it very worried he's so confused you
stand in silence with the stove on
Nick's look at the stove very worried he
has no idea what's going on and wishes
it would just end so do i Nick so do i
you open the fridge Nick looks at you I
didn't read that oh boy okay you know
what he thinks the little rude look
whose fridge without asking for his
buddy doesn't say anything okay alright
I apparently can't there we go uh
okay okay all right then turn it on you
turn it on but there's nothing inside so
it runs until it doesn't Nick looks of
you wondering what you're doing slightly
worried that it might be bad to run a
microwave with nothing in it let it run
Oh Nick looks at you and then at the
microwave wondering what you're doing
and why you're doing it he's very
confused so am i I don't know what's
happening hey I'm so confused
Oh Dell the bathroom would give you some
privacy oh boy oh boy okay play a movie
ask Nick where the tapes are he says he
doesn't have any which he realizes is
kind of weird and wanders and one
himself why he doesn't own any yeah
there is a little weird turn it on but
don't play a movie we turn on the VCR
with no intention to watching a movie
Nick wonders what you're doing stand in
silence
Nick wonders if you're not thinking
about your next move or something else
entirely he thinks about this and then
thinks ha thinking on this feels
uncomfortable with the silence okay you
know what must sit it's just that long
monotonous tone in the background is
horrible oh hey why is this on your
computer Nick oh my god okay all right
then huh I'm gonna leave this ends the
game
you leave nick is sad to see you go and
he hopes you'll come back again please
send an email - OH - Nick K at gmail and
tell him what you did today so he can
feel like he was there as well thank you
what did I pay why me cheeks man what
the [ __ ] happened
who's the point of that okay we gotta
find out what the [ __ ] the point of that
was oh my god
this is so creepy this is so creepy oh
man this is so creepy well this
definitely was it experience I'll tell
you that haha check out my video of what
we did I enjoyed her time together
haha and then Nick it's responding thank
you so much for playing and you made a
video so I feel like I'm even there oh I
thought he was gonna kill me if I kept
turning off the lights thank you for
playing and Tommy telling me what you
did I feel like I was there watching you
rummage through my closets he would
never kill you we just want to be
friends dude thank you so much for
playing oh my god oh no oh no well maybe
maybe I'm being too harsh maybe I'm
being too harsh oh maybe I'm being too
harsh maybe I acts maybe it maybe I need
to give Nick another chance here I kind
of rushed into this maybe I need to like
go back into Nick's house I gotta I got
a pain ick another visit here because I
feel like maybe I was being a little too
harsh in my judgment of this hello where
are you oh hi hey thanks for coming over
what do you want to do you know uh maybe
sit on the couch and start a
conversation Nick you are a cool guy and
I like you Hey want to watch me go to
the bathroom I bet not yeah I see that
shadow behind me Nick I see that shadow
you have mad about something nuke oh god
what the five [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
this Nick Nick Nick Nick I don't get it
Nick don't you get in here I closed the
door got a close dark head closed door
close the door
why a [ __ ] [ __ ] Nick hi wow you are
very close to me alright okay alright
you know what I'm gonna let me go now
Nick I'm inside you Nick hi hey friend
Hey whoa nice head inside your head
hey hey Nick how's it goin there buddy
you know what I've always admired you oh
boy oh boy oh boy okay Nick you know
what I'm just gonna I'm gonna you know
I'm gonna leave you to your life I'm
gonna I'm gonna go I'm gonna get out of
here oh boy oh boy Nick
oh boy Nick oh boy oh boy oh boy I have
no [ __ ] idea what's going on here but
I feel like there's a deep dark secret
that I don't know about the night I
think Nick is a nice guy but I'm not
absolutely sure about that
I said Nick Mike I mean there's
objectively there's nothing wrong with
Nick and I'm the weird one going into
his house and messing with his stuff but
somehow I don't feel comfortable here
around dick but by all means big has
been a nice guy this is for some reason
that a monotonous tone driving me insane
Nick
okay oh yeah so anyway I'm gonna leave
it at that
if you guys want to party with Nik I'll
put the game down in the description
below to where you can have a fun time
all day with Nick who is just a cool
naked guy anyway thanks again everybody
for watching as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]